l'enthousiasmé tel au sein du caucus néo
démocrate on a presque l'impression que
c'est leur chef le grand vainqueur
thomas mulcair tente tant bien que mal
de ne pas se montrer triomphaliste
cette victoire appartient d'abord et
avant tout aux jeunes
les néo-démocrates avaient de quoi
chanter cette victoire ils en avaient
bien besoin pour se présenter comme une
alternative crédible pour pouvoir
conservateur l'un dé nous sommes bien
positionnés avec des racines au québec
imaginez les nazis n'avaient pas aussi
alors tout est possible
ils ont bourré vite ils savent aussi que
cette victoire en alberta est davantage
celle de la chef riccio nhat ly une
certaine prudence s'impose les gens
soient tous changements positifs
constructeurs sont rempli d'optimisme
avec cette victoire et ça augure super
bien pour l'avenir de l'ensemble du
travail du npd à travers le canada
le changement si le message n'a pas
passé pour les libéraux albertain justin
trudeau aussi qu'il devra l'incarner sur
la scène fédérale
les gens cherchent leurs plans une
meilleure vision est l'alternative
même si c'est quelque chose de différent
et surtout c'est que c'est quelque chose
de nouveau
de l'autre côté du couloir le contraste
est frappant les visages sont longs le
coup est difficile à encaisser
atmosphère de mort s'il en est une les
colonnes de leur temple ébranlé les
conservateurs ont beau vouloir éviter
les comparaisons parallèle ils admettent
cette fois ci que des leçons s'impose
pas question surtout de se mettre à dos
ce nouveau gouvernement néo démocrate
qui a su gagner la confiance des
électeurs conservateurs en alberta nous
avons une relation très forte dans le
secteur énergique et
je ne crois pas que ça va changer avec
une telle vague emmanuel commence que
les conservateurs vont devoir composer
avec une première ministre néo-démocrate
en territoire qui est traditionnellement
conservateur d'essayer de la réalité
c'est qu'ils ont pas trop choix du moins
à court terme
salut aujourd'hui le bureau du premier
ministre nous dit que steven un peu à
une conversation téléphonique cordiales
avec riccio 90 lits dans laquelle il
leur a indiqué qu'il a espoir de la
rencontre et lorsqu'il sera de passage
en alberta c'est intéressant aussi de
voir aujourd'hui comment madame marie a
tenu à ne pas s'immiscer dans le débat
partisan fédéral entend que était la
première ministre de l'alberta devraient
travailler avec ottawa sur des dossiers
mais potentiellement litigieux comme les
changements climatiques les dossiers
énergétiques en termes de conséquences
électorales ici deux choses a souligné
les conservateurs disent oui c'est vrai
hier c'est la défaite de jim prentice
avant tout ce qui les inquiète c'est que
il ya beaucoup de contenus n'ont jamais
vraiment eu d'opposition
les députés 10 mai prochain coup il ya
fort à parier qu'on va avoir un
adversaire néo-démocrate crédible mieux
organisés
surtout plusieurs se posent des
questions est ce que le résultat va voir
ce vent de changement et pourrait en
être inspiré une leçon que tous les
partis se tiennent ici le déjà dit
céline une campagne électorale c'est
long ça compte ça peut faire la
différence
oui en tout cas ce qu on a fait une
grosse cette fois-ci merci beaucoup et
manuel très bien revoir